cette vie au jour le jour ça vous ennuie
pas vous êtes libre
oui sauf que je demande de l'argent au
bourgeois qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
demander de l'argent au bourgeois ça me
fait rire et vous croyez pas que vous
les faites rire avec votre chapeau
ridicule le Paris d'hier celui de
François Villon avec en toile de fond la
tour de nelle annonçait déjà celui de
Victor Hugo NotreDame de Paris sa
majesté et la misère galeuse et sordide
qui grouillit alentour de son
parvi les chevelus les hirsutes d'alors
vivant d'un Couton trempé dans un maigre
bouillon habitaient volontiers ces
châteaux des courand d'air aux façad
rongé par la
mousse le soir à l'heure où les
bourgeois étaient couchés la Cour des
Miracles soudain s'animait sous l'œil
vigilante et terrible de son roi le roi
d'Égypte maître absolu des lieux et du
troupeau de bohémien et de galvau de qui
l'
hantait le jour les bords de scène de la
cité étaient déjà l'endroit de
prédilection de ses
[Musique]
vanupi le Paris d'aujourd'hui les
retrouve changer bien sûr car on
évolue chaque printemps les voi
réapparaître transfuge des
pseudophilosophes de la près-guerre qui
sous la banière de l'existentialisme
militaire principalement aux terrasses
des cafés du vieux
Saint-Germain phénomène cyclique s'il en
est mais qui semble prendre une nouvelle
dimension ce n'est en effet plus à
l'échelon national qu'il faut considérer
problème mais bien à celui de la planète
les qua de scène du vieux Paris sont
devenus la nouvelle Babelle de cet
univers où le peig et la brosse sont
bannisce
qu' un garçon une fille
dépenaillé un peu
crasseux et qui vit on ne sait comment
moi je suis le des bnique qu'est-ce que
c'est qu' bque un bque c'est un garçon
qui dessine par
terre comme on dit en anglais c'est un
garçon de petite
fille ça vous plaît vous changeriez
non qu'est-ce que vous faites tous les
jours par terre je vousz l'argent sur
vous non j'ai 20 C comment allezv manger
demain je vais dessiner ce
soir vie jour le jour pas vous êtes
libre oui sauf que je demande de
l'argent au
bourgeois qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
demander de l'argent au bourgeois ça me
fait rire vous croyez pas que vous les
faites rire avec votre chapeau
ridicule
si ça pas parce
que s'habiller avec une cravate
s'abiller avec un chapeau
ridiculeett une chemise noire une
cravate blanche aussi bien ricule un ch
ricule où est-ce que vous habitez dans
un château si vous voulez je peux vous
faire visiter
alors là c'est le château c'est la
qu'onit tous les soirs je monte les
escaliers que je suis en train de monter
je les monte le cœur en joie je suis pas
le type qui pleure c'est pas très propre
mais nous les femmes de chambre c'est
bourgeois moi j'ai ma chambre puisque je
suis le PAP des bniqu j'ai des bouquins
je bouine j'écris des poèmes aussi joue
de la guitare j'ai pas de drap les draps
ça me gratte ça me donne des
cauchemars on est tous là c'est là qu'on
V ça nous convient pour rien au monde
voudrait changer et bien ces jeunes ils
extériorisent quelque chose quoi tous
les désirs de
l'adolescence révolte contre la famille
révolte contre la société la recherche
de quelque
chose si on leur pose la question
nettement ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils
cherchent il cherche je n'en sais rien
je n'en sais
rien je cherche même pas à savoir je
continue à vivre et puis c'est tout
est-ce que tu as une ambition non même
pas de vivre je Tai déjà dit rien
d'autre ça paraît stupide enfin je n'ai
pas d'ambition sinon de réaliser
moi-même intérieurement peut-être tu es
heureuse je ne suis pas malheureuse en
tout cas je pense je fais ça par jeu
j'aime bien faire un peu ce que je veux
et là je fais un peu ce que je veux et
je viens uniquement pour pour m'amuser
mais vivre toujours non je pense pas
parce que j'ai besoin de mes parents
j'ai besoin de mon ma petite chambre
enfin je suis très bourgeoise finalement
dans dans mes je crois que c'est assez
profondément ancré en moi et surtout il
s'efforce de vivre de
rien ici dans le quartier tout près il y
a une soupe allez la voir et vous en
verrez des
dizaines tous les soirs ils viennent de
tous les pays du monde il parlent toutes
les
langues et ils ont un lien dès qu'ils se
rencontrent c'est fini ils se
comprennent ils se lit parce qu'ils sont
bicnique pas un vrai qu'est-ce qu'un
vrai bitnique un vrai bitnique les
bitnique tout le temps moi je suis
seulement le soir et le weekend j'ai
parlé avec un très grand nombre et
chaque fois surtout avec les Scandinaves
il y a une chose les familles étent
d'accord pour qu'il tente l'expérience
moi j'ai 15 ans vos parents savent que
vous menez ce genre de vie ouais il ça
il n'ont rien contre Paron il n'ont rien
contre non il n'ont rien contre vous ne
faites rien de mal non je fais pas de
mal ils savent que je me promène sur les
c que je connais quelques bicque j'aime
pas tellement ce mot mais enfin que je
connais quelques personnes ici ils sont
pas tellement pas tellement ravis mais
enfin je crois qu'ils réalisent pas
tellement ils savent pas pas trop ce
dont il s'agit ils connaissent pas du
tout ce
[Musique]
milieu
90 % de ces bitniqu après avoir mené un
an ou deux ce genre de vie se réintègre
de même dans la société c'est d'ailleurs
souvent dans le mariage qu'il retrouve
le calme d'une vie tranquille sans
[Musique]
histoire
d'autres peu nombreux réussissent dans
un métier qui n'était auparavant qu'une
excuse le peintre bitnique un jour
devient célèbre l'écrivain écrit un jour
un roman à succès le poète son recueil
qui sera imprimé par un grand éditeur
les autres les 10 % qui restent eux
vieillissent ils s'enfoncent s'égrissent
de plus en plus à mesure que leurs
cheveux poussent et se retrouve à 40 50
ans clochard sans but sans espoir que
celui d'une soupe populaire plus
hebdomadaire que
quotidienne
[Musique]
ce phénomène social des bitnx ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui car ils ont toujours
existé sous d'autres appellations ce qui
nouveau c'est le nombre croissant et la
vitesse avec laquelle il se déplace
c'est néanmoins Paris qui les attire le
[Musique]
plusit une fois à Paris que fontil qui
les occupe comment passe-t-il le temps
j'évite au maximum de travailler
pourquoi tu n'aimes pas travailler non
je n'aime pas ça je refuse de donner 8h
de ma vie par jour pour pouvoir vivre 2h
et un weekend mais comment 8h par jour
alors je te dis à vivre enfin quoi le
travail obligatoire n'a pas toujours
existé je vis je j'écoute mes amis qui
jouent de la musique je peins je me
promène je regarde la nature je regardé
j'ai discuté avec les amis j'établi les
[Musique]
contacts